So today I'm talking with Andrei Pop,
the Founder and
Chief Executive of Human API.
Andrei is my favorite kind of person.
An entrepreneur trained
in Political Science at
the University of British Columbia.
He is now starting his
second technology company.
>> Thanks so much for having me.
>> So, the Human API is the luster
of a lot of the things that we have
talked about so far in the course.
I am very excited to have you here,
because it brings together many pieces
in a tangible way, that's easy to
understand and easy to demonstrate.
So let's start by talking about
the fundamentals of what you do.
And for that,
we've assembled a few toys here, right?
>> Let's do it.
>> So I'm a patient and this device
is measuring my blood pressure, or
my activity, or whatever.
Tell me what you can do for
me, starting at that device.
>> And so the idea for us, really was,
we wanted to make it really simple for
this data to flow from this device
into wherever it needed to go, whether
that was for research, for a doctor,
for a nurse practitioner, you name it.
And so what this device would have, and
sort of the other really important part
of this system is somewhere over here in
a totally different part is you have a,
say personal health record system and
it's floating away from me, but
let's just use this for the time being.
So you start with this, and what we
said is, okay, this device will now,
already has a connection to
a phone of some kind, right?
>> A phone.
>> Let's put that there.
Great.
>> And then somewhere along the way,
it finds its way into a cloud
system of some kind, right?
So now you've got blood
pressure data that's flowing
from this device to the phone
into this cloud system.
And then over here, you've got-
>> And typically, this cloud system
would be provided by the company that
provides the device, that's the norm.
>> That's right, that's right.
But now, you're over here, and
you're talking to your doctor.
And you're trying to say okay,
I've collected all of this
blood pressure data, and
I'd like to actually get it into
the system, how do I do that?
And so that's where we come in.
So what we provide is,
you essentially, and
I'll show you how this
works a little later on.
But you essentially would click a button
inside of this personal health record
system.
You know, just like you were
logging into an app with Facebook.
And what would then happen is we would
say look, we're going to grab your
data from this blood pressure device,
we being Human API.
We're going to pull it into our back
end, we're going to structure and
normalize it, and
then we will send it onto there.
And so I'll show you how that works.
But essentially, we now sit right
in the middle here, and this is us.
And so, now the data's flowing from this
device through the phone up to the cloud
service to us, and
to the person who holds the records.
>> And of course, it wouldn't
just be data from this device,
it could be data from several devices?
>> Of course.
>> It could be data the patient
has recorded in their PHR.
>> Right.
>> Could be any health data really,
disassembled into this
patient controlled database.
>> That's right.
So now, for example, let's say you
have a different device over here and
then you're trying to
query data from that, and
same sort of tree-like structure
that would flow down from there.
And now here's where it
gets really interesting, so
now that we have the central identity
that you can query through an API,
as long as the patient grants access.
Let's say you're using a totally
different personal health record system,
right, so you've got some
other application over here.
We've already got your data here,
so now, all you need to do
is go inside of the system, click our
button and the connection is made.
And now any time you capture
blood pressure on this device,
it will automatically flow up the chain
and into all of these different systems.
>> So that's what Human API does.
>From the point of view of the course,
maybe the more interesting
story is how you do it.
So for that, we're going to clear
the table and let's take a look.
So I guess this is a PHR or some other
tool that the patient might be using.
>> Right, exactly.
So for example,
we mentioned that connect
button that allows you to pull data
from all of these different devices.
So what we've actually done
here is this would be some sort
of personal health record system and
somewhere inside of here, you'd have
this connect your health data button.
And now what you do when you click that
button, is we serve up this pop-up
that basically says look, this wellness
portal, or PHR system wants permission
to access your health data, and we're
going to pull it through Human API.
Now this is really important because
central to our philosophy in
how we approach this business
is to put the patient
in the driver's seat in this case.
So what ends up happening is the patient
grants access to the system.
Now, what's happening on the back end
here is we've created an identity for
that patient in our system.
And we're essentially saying look,
now we have all of these different
sources so, for this example Fitbit,
Jawbone, Nike, and Moves, but
it could be any one of these, right?
And so might say, okay, let's go
ahead and authenticate a Fitbit, or
let's go ahead and authenticate
a Moves application against Human API.
And so this allows us to connect each
of those different data sources, and
it could be a blood pressure monitor,
it could be another PHR system,
you name it.
>> And so Moves is an app that
keeps track of people's activity.
>> Right, that's right.
>> And FitBit is another approach to
keeping track of people's activity
through a device.
>> Right.
That's right.
>> One using the phone,
one using the device.
>> So that's actually a really,
really important point as well,
because what we do on our end that also
sort of helps move this process along
from the perspective of the application
that's pulling in our data,
is we actually normalize this data.
So if you think about having steps,
for example,
as a metric that's being recorded, maybe
by an app on your phone, maybe out by
a pedometer you wear, maybe by a smart
watch that has an accelerometer in it.
All of the data from the perspective of
the application is actually just steps.
And so, what we do on our end is we
structure and normalize that data before
we send it on to the application, which
makes it much easier for them to use it.
>> This is a really key point.
>> Right.
>> As everyone taking the course
knows interoperability is one of
the overriding challenges
in health informatics.
And you sit in the middle and
don't just aggregate the data.
But you put it in a standard syntax so
that it's much easier on the other
side to access the data as we'll see.
>> Right.
So
yeah, why don't I show you
kind of how that works.
So I will go to here and
I will show you.
You saw that authentication process
sort of happen on the back end, right?
So once that authentication
process has happened,
the data starts flowing from Human APIs
or from the device to Human API.
And into these various systems, right?
Now, what does this actually look like?
Well, if you have, and, you know, for to
kind of geek out a little bit here but,
we basically give an access token for
a user to the application.
So, in this case,
we're using the demo access token but
each user of the application would
have their own unique token, and
then it's a restful API
that we can query in.
So we say look,
api.humanapi.co human blood pressure.
And here you can see structured data,
systolic and
diastolic blood pressure that's come off
of a Withings blood pressure monitor.
And then one thing you can do here
is actually change the date range.
For example, you can sort of
modify this query on the fly.
So, if you're building an experience for
a physician that wants to look at this
data at some point,
you as an application developer can
choose how you interpret this data for
that physician once it's in your system.
If, for example,
you wanted to actually visualize it,
we can do that on the fly as well.
So rather than using
the api.humanapi.coendpoint,
you would just use chart and
then there it is.
And if you wanted to change
the dimensions of this or
do any of that stuff,
you can do that on the fly as well.
>> So, it's important to look at
the URI here, the restful API.
And see how simple it is.
And in fact,
it's actually human readable.
>> Right.
>> So getting to this data becomes much,
much simpler.
And there's only a reference
here to blood pressure.
And the app developer or
the query, the source
that screened the data doesn't have
to know what device is being used.
Doesn't have to know
anything about that device.
Doesn't have to understand their data
streams, or formats, or syntaxes.
They're going to get it in
the standard form through your system.
>> Exactly.
So, what we do is we
abstract all of that away.
So, if you actually look
at our back end here,
you'll see we have this tool
we call the API explorer.
And what you can essentially do in here
is you can see all the different types
of data that you can query, so blood
glucose, blood pressure levels, BMI.
So, really important to this idea of
normalization is we're not actually
taking Whithing's data, for example, and
just passing it on to the developers.
What we're actually doing is making
sure that the data is very clean and
very structured.
And that enables the application
developer to really focus
on the experience that they want to
create without worrying about where
the data comes from and all that stuff.
>> Well, this is great.
This is an example,
I think of the future of
interoperability
>> Thank you.
>> So I'm glad that we're able to
show the students tomorrow today.
Thanks for coming.
>> Thank you so much for having me.